Valérie a choisi de vivre l’aventure
avec Karine son ami de toujours
totalement fusionnel elles sont pourtant
très différentes elle est très positive
voilà moi je peux voir plutôt la
bouteille à moitié vide elle la voit à
moitié plein
je suis votre marraine François et j'ai
appris hier que vous partiez je suis
encore sous le choc c'est vrai que je
vous ai pas consulté je trouve ça très
impertinent de votre part j'aurais
peut-être dû demander à la marraine ce
qu'elle en
pensait-il possible d'y avoir un biseau
entre vous deux s'il vous plaît depuis
sa fenêtre et avec son mégaphone Matteo
veut répondre le bonheur en bas de chez
lui on se tient la main quand on marche
dans la rue évidemment que je vous
aurais donné raison mais au moins
j'aurais pu vous montrer l'émotion que
ça produisait sur moi tandis que là vous
me prenez je dois assumer cette émotion
presque en direct
plutôt dans la journée certains élus de
la nuque organisent même à un mariage
fictif entre Emmanuel Macron
et Marine Le Pen
aujourd'hui il y a plus de fonds
républicains et le fonds républicain il
est bafouille mais à ce jeu politique
toute la gauche n'a pas envie de
participer quand je pense cette image va
rester dans l'éternité
voilà je peux vous assurer qu'il fait
très très chaud sous les 50 t-shirts et
que on a du mal à se mouvoir et on se
sent aussi un peu ridicule mais que
c'est un jeu il faut accepter que des
moments où on se sent pas forcément à
son avantage d'ailleurs vous êtes prêts
les socialistes qui ont refusé
d'intégrer la Nupe et les radicaux de
gauche affiche un sourire amer il
n'approuve pas du tout la méthode
nous voulons que notre pays avance et
nous ne voulons pas de la paralysie donc
voilà nous nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une démarche constructive
Amazon vous proposera bientôt de
poursuivre la discussion avec vos
proches à travers la mort ça ressemble à
un film de science-fiction et pourtant
il ne suffirait à l'intelligence
artificielle que une seule minute
d'enregistrement audio pour imiter la
voix la démonstration a d'ailleurs été
faite il y a quelques jours à Las Vegas
par la firme américaine dans une vidéo
on voit un enfant s'adresser à
l'assistant vocal et demander si sa
grand-mère peut lui dire une histoire
quelques secondes plus tard la voix de
la grand-mère lui lit le Magicien d'Oz
je sais pas si on a le temps rapidement
pour faire un petit quiz allez on va
faire un quiz je vous montre une photo
de une personne
âgée et vous allez savoir voilà ce
moustachu non chanteur
Freddie Mercury
sur les réseaux sociaux les profils
transformés en compte commémoratif se
multiplient des chercheurs estime même
tenez-vous bien qu'en 2050 il y aura
davantage de profils de personnes
décédées sur Facebook que de vivantes et
un autre Laurent Voulzy
pas vrai Joey Starr alors
Kendrix quand même vous voyez ces
gens-là comprend pensent très dermelles
ils sont français et je veux pas être
désobligeants d'ailleurs à l'encontre de
faire d'un mail parce que je pense que
like a des propos que même Julien audoul
bourré ne tiendrait pas il faut pas
attention monsieur elles sont à ce que
vous dites simplement
il a plus cheveux que moi de toute façon
je pense mais après avoir réalisé une
pelote d'excréments ils la font rouler
tant bien que mal jusqu'à leur terrier
là il l'enterreront pour protéger les
œufs que la femelle a déposé à
l'intérieur
et la France sera son travail et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire avoir une idéologie
n'est pas répréhensible en droit
français
aux gens du 13 septembre
la vache